The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation, or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: OK, let us start.
So let me first remind you
what we did in last lecture.
We proved-- we showed that the
Weinberg-Witten theorem for
beats existence of
massless spin-2 particles.
Massless spin-2 particles
are hallmark of gravity,
so that's why we look for them.
In the same-- so emphasize
in the same space time,
say a QFT lives.
So this theorem
essentially cites this.
You will never have
emergent gravity start
from a [INAUDIBLE] quantum
field theory, which is
a well-defined stress tensor.
So as we already
mentioned, it's a new pole
of this theorem is that actually
emergent gravity can actually
live in a different space time.
So as in a holographic duality.
In fact, in holographic
duality the gravity
lives in one dimension
higher, but we are not
ready to go there yet.
So in order to
describe this thing
we still need to do
some preparations.
So the preparations-- let me
just outline the preparations
we need to do.
So the first thing we will do
is black hole thermodynamics.
So these will give
hint for something
called the holographic
principle, which is actually
more general than the
holographic duality discovered
so far.
And the second thing
is, we will also quickly
go over the large
N gauge theory--
the properties of the
large N gauge theories.
So this give hints-- something
called a gauge string duality.
So the behavior of the
large N gauge theory
give you a strong hint
that actually there's
a string theory description
for ordinary gauge theories.
OK, and then when you combine
these two things together,
then you get what
we have currently,
the holographic duality.
And then we will also talk a
little bit of sting theory.
A tiny bit.
Not a lot, so don't be scared.
So we also will talk a little
bit about string theory.
So in principle, actually, I can
talk about holographic duality
right now, but going
over those aspect
can help you to build
some intuitions,
and also to have a broader
perspective than just
presenting the duality directly.
So before I start
today's lecture,
do you have any questions
regarding our last lecture
and regarding this-- yeah,
general remarks here?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So moving
forward, are we
going to define emergent
gravity as this existence
of a massless spin-2 particle?
PROFESSOR: No, that
we will not do.
AUDIENCE: So how are we
defining emergent gravity?
PROFESSOR: You
construct Newton's Law?
Yeah, you will see it.
You will see it when we have it.
Yeah, essentially you
see-- essentially it's
handed over to you.
You don't have to go
through that step.
Yeah.
Any other questions?
OK, good, let's start with
black hole thermodynamics.
So let me start by
doing a little bit
of dimensional analysis, just
to remind you important scales
for the gravity.
So the first thing is what
we called the Planck scale.
So in nature we have
fundamental constant H-bar,
Newton constant, and
the C, speed of light.
And immediately after Planck
himself introduced this H-bar,
he realized you can actually
combine the three of them
to come up with a map scale,
which is just hc divided by GN.
And this, if you plug in the
expressed numerical value,
it's about 1.2 to the 10, to the
19 gev, divided by c squared.
You can also write it in terms
of the gram, which is about 2.2
10 to the minus 5 gram.
And then you can also
have-- we can also
construct the length scale,
which is hGN divide c cubed,
which is about 1.6 to 10
the minus 33 centimeter.
And tp equals lp
divided by c, OK?
So this was discovered--
Planck introduced them
in 1899, so most of
you may know the story.
And then, just immediately
after he introduced H-bar-- so
he introduced H-bar in 1899.
In the same year he realized you
can write down those numbers.
And of course, those
numbers meant nothing to him
because at that time he didn't
know special relativity,
he didn't know quantum
mechanics-- essentially,
he didn't know anything.
But he famously said
that this unit-- so he
claimed those should be
basic units of physics,
and he also said these
are the units that
would retain their significance
for all times and all cultures.
He even said they even
will apply to aliens.
But only after 50 years--
so after 1950s people
get some sense.
So many years after
special relativity,
many years after
general relativity,
and also quantum mechanics,
et cetera, people
started grasping the
meaning of those scales.
And so let me
briefly review them.
So you can-- OK, the feeling
of the meaning of those scales
by looking at the
strength of gravity.
So let me first start this
example for electromagnetism,
which you have a
potential, which
is e squared divided by r.
So if you have two charged
particle of charge e,
then the potential between
them is e squared divided by r.
And then for particle
of mass m then
you also have
Compton wavelengths.
So if you have a
particle with mass m,
you also have
Compton wavelengths.
It's H-bar divided my mc.
So you can get rough
measure of the strength
of electromagnetism--
the actual strength
of the electromagnetism
by conceiving
the following [INAUDIBLE]
dimension number, which
I call lambda e, which is
the potential evaluated
at the minimal-- in
quantum mechanics,
essentially this is the minimal
distance you can make sense of.
Because once you go
distance smaller than these,
you can no longer-- and
then the quantum uncertainty
will create the energy
uncertainty bigger than m,
and you can no longer
talk about single particle
in a sensible way.
So the essentially
the minimal length
scale you can talk
about single particles.
So this is essentially
some energy scale.
So you can compare these to
the, say, the static mass
of the particle.
So this give you a
measure of the strength
of electromagnetism.
Of course, if you
plug this in you
just get e squared
divided by H-bar c.
And of course, we know this is
the fine structure constant,
which is indeed the coupling.
Say you would do-- indeed,
it's a coupling in QED, OK?
So you can do the same
thing for gravity.
You can do the same
So for gravity we have
essentially g, and say
if you take two
particle of masses
m then the potential between
them is gm, m squared,
divided by r.
And then again, you can
define effective strength
for the gravity.
I evaluate this potential
at Compton wavelengths
divided by the static
energy of the particle.
And then you can
just plug this in.
So this is GN m squared,
divided by H-bar, divided by mc,
then divided by mc squared.
And then you find this is just
equal to GN m squared, divided
by H-bar c.
OK, so now if you compare
with this equation--
OK, so this is just given by m
squared divided by mp squared.
OK, so for gravity
this effective strength
is just given by the
mass of the particle.
So because for
gravity the mass is
like some kind of
effective charge,
and then divided
by Planck scale--
this Planck mass-- squared.
OK, and you can also write
it as lp squared divided
by rc squared, or just
as this Planck length
divided by [INAUDIBLE]
wavelengths of this particle.
OK, so for most
elementary particles--
so for typical
elementary particles
we know the m is always
much smaller than mp.
And then the lambda g would be
typically much smaller than 1.
So for example, say, if
you can see the electron,
the electron mass
would be 5 to the 10
to the minus 4 gev
divided by c squared.
Of course this is much
smaller than this Planck mass.
And then you find that
this ratio-- so you
can work out this ratio.
So let's compare it to
the corresponding strength
for electromagnetism.
So this is about 10 to the
minus 43 if you work this out.
So this tells you the
gravity's really weak.
So for ordinary
elementary particles--
so the gravity is
really weak, and so we
can forget all about gravity
until you reach the Planck
mass, or your
Compton wavelengths
reach the Planck length.
And then the fact of the quantum
gravity will be important.
So from this exercise we know
that the mp is the energy
scale, that the effective
gravity strength become
of order one-- become of order
one-- that is, quantum gravity
fact becomes significant.
And similarly-- so lp is the
corresponding length scale
associated with such energy.
So this give you a
heuristic feeling--
give you a heuristic
indication that the meaning
of those Planck scales.
OK, so there's another important
scale associated with gravity.
So any questions on this?
Good, there's another important
scale associated with gravity.
It's called Schwarzschild
radius-- Schwarzschild radius.
So just from
dimensional analysis,
the Schwarzschild radius
can be argued as follows.
So can see that--
again, we can just even
see from Newtonian gravity.
So I would say let's consider
the object of mass m.
Then we ask is the
distance-- at what distance,
maybe I should-- at
what distance from it
the classical gravity
becomes strong.
So for this purpose,
let's consider,
say, a probe mass--
say, m prime.
So, can see the probe mass.
So I define a scale
which I call rs,
as I require the potential
energy between m and m prime.
at such a scale rs, then
this become of order,
say again, the static energy
of this probe political,
or of this probe mass.
So if you cancel
things out then you
find rs is of order GNm
divided by c squared.
OK, so this give you--
I'll give you a scale.
You can also ask-- so this
is from Newtonian gravity.
Of course, when your
gravity becomes strong
you should replace
the Newtonian gravity
by Einstein, the relativity.
And then when you
go to relativity--
when you go to relativity,
general relativity,
then you find then there's
a Schwarzschild radius.
So there's a
Schwarzschild radius
which given by 2 gm divided by
c squared, which corresponding
to the sides of a black hole.
OK, corresponding to the
sides of a black hole.
So this is a classical scale--
purely classical scale.
Just the scale which
the classical gravity
becomes strong.
In particular, rs
can be considered
as the minimal length scale one
can probe an object of mass m,
OK?
So classically, black
hole absorb everything.
So once you fall into black
hole you can never come back.
And so the minimal
distance you can
approach an object of mass m,
it is given by the Schwarzschild
radius.
So when you go inside
the Schwarzschild radius
we just fall into
the black hole,
and you can never
send information out.
And the one interesting
thing compare--
yeah, one interesting thing
regarding this Schwarzschild
radius.
You said Schwarzschild
radius increase with mass.
OK, if you increase the mass the
Schwarzschild radius increases.
So in principal it
can be very large
when you can see the very
large object-- when you can
see the very massive object.
So now-- so let us summarize.
Let us summarize.
So for object of mass m there
are two important scales.
Two important scales.
So one is just the standard
Compton wavelengths,
and the other is the
Schwarzschild radius.
So one is quantum and
the other is classical.
The other is classical.
So let's take the
ratio between them.
Let's take the
So if you take the ratio
between them-- so let's
forget about these two,
just to consider of order
up to order 1.
So c squared, divided
by H-bar, divided by mc.
And then this again give you gm
m squared divided by H-bar c.
And then this is again just m
squared divided by mp squared.
This again is m squared
divided mp squared,
and p is the Planck mass.
So let's consider the
different scenarios.
So the first, let's
consider-- just
suppose the mass of the object
is much, much greater than mp.
OK, so in this case then
the Schwarzschild radius
are much larger than
the Compton wavelengths.
Much larger than the Compton
wavelengths, And essentially,
all of physics is controlled
by the classical gravity,
because you can no
longer probe-- yeah,
because a Compton
wavelengths is much,
much inside the Schwarzschild
radius, which you cannot probe.
So the physics is essentially
classical gravity.
And the quantum effect
is not important,
so you don't have to worry
about the quantum effect.
I will put quote here.
Not quote, I will to put
some-- yeah, some quote here.
You will see what this means.
And the second possibility
is for mass much,
much smaller than p.
So in this case, then
the Compton wavelengths
will be much, much greater
than the Schwarzschild radius.
OK, so this is a quantum
object, so the quantum size
is much larger than the
Schwarzschild radius.
But we also know,
precisely in this region,
this lambda g is
also very small.
The effective strength
of the gravity
is also very, very small.
So we also have found before
that the lambda g is also
very, very small.
So in this case, as
what we said here--
the gravity is very
weak and not important.
It's much, much weaker
than other interactions,
so you can essentially
ignore them.
Then we're only left
with the single scale
which mass is of all the mp.
And then, as we said before, the
quantum gravity is important.
So let me just say,
quantum gravity important.
If this were the full story,
then life would be very boring.
Even though it would
be very simple.
Because the only scale you need
to worry about quantum gravity
is essentially natural zero.
It's only one scale.
And it will take
us maybe hundred
if not thousand years
to reach that scale
by whatever accelerator
or other probes.
So there's really no urgency
to think about the quantum
gravity.
Because right now we are
at this kind of scale.
Right now we are
this kind of scale.
It's very, very far
from this kind of scale.
But the remarkable thing about
black hole-- so this part
of the physics is
essentially controlled
by Schwarzschild radius,
because the Schwarzschild
radius is the minimal classical
radius you can achieve.
Yeah, you can probe the
system, and the quantum physics
is relevant.
But the remarkable thing
is that it turns out
that this statement
is not correct.
This statement is not correct.
Actually, quantum
effect is important.
So the remarkable thing
is that the black hole
can have quantum effect manifest
at the microscopic level.
Say, at length scale of order
Schwarzschild radius, OK?
So that's why it makes the
black hole so interesting,
and also makes why black hole
is such a rich source of insight
and information if you want
to know about quantum gravity.
And as we will see,
actually, we also
contain a rich
source information
about ordinary many body
systems, due to this duality.
Any questions regarding this?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So when I talk about
the m much larger than mp,
so the m is not only
an elementary particle,
it can be just and object?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, it
can be a bound state.
So it can be-- here, we always
talking about quantum object.
But it can have mass very large.
AUDIENCE: That's still
a quantum object?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
What you will not see
from a traditional way,
for such a large
mass object, you
will not see its
quantum uncertainty,
because quantum
uncertainty is tiny.
The Compton wavelengths
is very tiny,
and so the fluctuations
are very small.
And so you have to probe
very, very small in scale
to see its quantum-- from
traditional point of view,
we have to probe very,
very small in scale
to see its quantum fluctuations.
And that scale is
much, much smaller
than the Schwarzschild radius.
AUDIENCE: OK.
PROFESSOR: Any other question?
Good, so let me-- before
we talk more specific
about black holes, let me
just make one final remark.
It's that in a sense,
this Planck length--
this length scale
defined by Planck
can be considered as a
minimal localization length.
OK, for the following reason.
So let's firstly imagine in
non gravitational physics--
so in non gravitational
physics if you
want to probe some short
distance scales then
it's easy if you
are rich enough.
Then you just
accelerate the particles
to very high energies.
Say e plus, e minus,
with p and minus p.
Then that can probe
the distance scale,
then this can probe
length scales.
Say of order h divided by p.
OK, so if you make the
particle energy high enough
you can, in principle, probe as
short as any scale as you want.
Anything, as far as you can make
this p as large as you want.
So in principle, you can
take l all the way to zero.
So the scale comes
all the way to 0.
If you take p, go to infinity.
But in gravity, this is not so.
So with gravity the square
of the distance [INAUDIBLE]
so when your energy is
much, much greater than ep--
say, the Planck
mass-- then, as we
discussed from there-- so this
is a central mass energy, OK?
Say if your central
mass image becomes
much, much larger than
the Planck scale-- Planck
mass-- then rs controlled
by the image-- yeah,
and [INAUDIBLE] p.
Yeah, let me just
forget about c.
Let me just say-- OK?
Then the Schwarzschild
radius from now
on-- so you go to y, OK?
So the Schwarzschild
radius will take over
as the minimal length scale.
OK, so what's going to happen is
that if you collided these two
particles at very high energies,
then at a certain point,
even before these two
particles meet together,
they already form a black holes
over the Schwarzschild sites,
OK?
If this energy is high enough,
then we will form black hole,
and then you can no longer
probe inside the Schwarzschild
radius of that black hole.
So that defines a new scale
which you can probe, OK?
So the funny thing about
this Schwarzschild radius
is that it's proportional
to energy, rather
inverse proportion to energy
as the standard Compton
wavelengths, OK?
So after a certain point, when
you go beyond the Planck mass,
when you further
increase in the energy,
then you're actually probing the
larger distance scales rather
than smaller distance scales,
due to the funny thing
about the gravity and the
funny thing about black hole.
OK, so actually, this scale
increases with p-- increase
with you center of mass energy.
OK, and the high energies
those two longer length scales.
OK, this essentially
defines the Planck length
as a minimal scale
one can probe.
OK, so when your
center of mass energy
is smaller than the Planck
scale-- than the Planck mass--
then your Compton wavelength
of course is larger than lp.
But when this is
greater than mp,
then as we discussed here--
then the Schwarzschild radius,
of course, [INAUDIBLE] object
will be greater than the Planck
side, and will break through
the common wavelengths
and will be greater
than the Planck sides.
And this give you, essentially,
the minimal radius to probe.
Alternatively, we can also
just reach the same argument.
Simply, I can just write
down a couple equations.
So let's consider
you have uncertainty.
So suppose you have a
position, data x, and then
the answer in the energy
or momentum associated
with the data x is data p.
But on the other hand,
the distance you can probe
must be greater than the
Schwarzschild radius associated
with lp, data p.
OK, data p.
So if you combine these
two equations together-- so
this is greater than
GN H-bar divided by lp.
So now I have suppressed the c.
So you can see from
this equation--
you can see that data
x must be greater
than H-bar GN, which is lp.
OK, which is lp here.
This is the same
argument as this one,
but this is a little bit formal.
So the essence is that once
you're energy is big enough,
then you will create
the black hole,
and then your physics
will completely change.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] black
hole evaporates [INAUDIBLE]
they do not contain
that information.
PROFESSOR: Right, yeah
so we will go into that.
When the black hole
evaporate, we still
don't probe the short--
it's still harder
to probe the short
distance scale.
Yeah, we will talk
about that later.
So yeah, here just
a heuristic argument
to tell you that because
of this, actually
the physics are very special.
The physics of the
gravity is very special.
Any another questions?
AUDIENCE: As a probe
for quantum gravity,
I was thinking-- what if
there were some phenomenon
in which gravity is weak,
and it's a macroscopic scale,
but there's some kind
of coherence happening
that will-- maybe on the
scale of galaxies or something
like that-- that will allow
quantum effects to manifest.
Like an analogy of what
happens in a laser or something
like that.
PROFESSOR: Yeah,
that is black hole.
The black hole is
the way which gravity
can manifest at the quantum
effect that matches in scales.
And we don't know any
other ways for gravity
to manifest such quantum physics
at large distance scales.
OK, so let me conclude this
I generally discussion.
Again, by reminding you
various regimes of gravity.
Various regimes of the
gravity or quantum gravity.
So in this
discussion, you should
always-- in the
discussion I'm going
to do in the next minutes,
you should always think,
when I take the limit I
always keep my energy fixed.
I keep the energy scale
I'm interested in fixed.
I keep that fixed.
So the classical gravity
regime is the regime
in which you take
H-bar equals zero--
take Newton constant finite--
and the regime of a particle
physics, we would
normally be, sometimes,
say, QFT in fixed space time.
So this is a
quantum field theory
in the fixed space
time, including
curved-- including curved.
So this is a regime in
which H-bar is finite,
while you take the
Newton constant go to 0.
And then there's, of course,
the quantum gravity regime,
which is the GN and
the H-bar both finite.
And then there's a very
interesting regime,
which is actually the
regime most of us work with.
So there's also something
called the semiclassical regime
for quantum gravity.
So this is the regime
you keep H-bar finite,
and you expand this system
in Newton constant, OK?
So around-- so you
expanded whatever
quantity Newton
constant around--
say G Newton equal to zero.
So G Newton equal to 0
is the classical regime.
It's the regime the
gravity's not important,
but including H-bar.
And now you can take into
account the quantum gravity
fact, semiclassically, by
expanding around the GN.
OK, so this is normally what
we call semiclassical regime
of gravity.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Do we know that
G goes to 0 [INAUDIBLE]
and it's not some other part?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, this
is a very good question.
So this is indeed the question.
Indeed, most of the particles
regarding black hole
is in this regime.
So our current understanding of
quantum physics or black hole
is in the semiclassical regime,
and you treat any matter field
H-bar finite, but
the gravity's weak.
And so there are
various indication
that this limit is
actually not smooth,
but the only for very
subtle questions.
For simple questions,
for typical questions,
actually this is a limit.
This limit is smooth, but there
can be very subtle questions
which this limit is not smooth.
And one such question is
this so-called the black hole
information loss,
and the subtle limit
of taking this-- yeah, you
[INAUDIBLE] taking this limit.
Any other questions?
And this is a regime, actually,
we will work with most.
OK, this is a regime
So we will always-- in
particular in nature.
So right there I'm keeping
the H-bar explicitly,
but later I will also
set the H-bar equal to 1.
And so H-bar will equal to-- so
we are always typically working
with this regime.
So H-bar equal to one.
And then you will
have-- yeah, then
you take into account
the fact of GN
in the perturbations series.
Good, so now let's
move to the black hole.
OK, with this-- yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
Also working
in the other
sermiclassical regime.
I mean finite GN,
but expand H-bar.
PROFESSOR: Yeah,
this is not so much.
It's because it's easy--
in some sense it's easy.
So in a sense, we are
doing a little bit both.
Yeah, so later-- right now I
don't want to go into that.
You will see the effective
coupling constant
and show the quantum gravity
fact is in fact H-bar times GN.
It's H-bar times GN.
And so the quantum gravity
fact will be important
when the H-bar times--
when you do perturbation
series H-bar times GN.
So when I say you are
doing same thing GN,
essentially it's because
I'm fixing H-bar.
So you're actually doing
perturbation series H-bar GN.
So you have to do both.
Any other questions?
Good.
Right, so now let's talk
about the black hole.
Let's talk about
classical geometry.
OK, so here I will
assume you already
have some background in
GR-- in general relativity--
and for example, you have
seen since Schwarzschild
metric, et cetera.
And if you have not seen
a Schwarzschild metric,
it's also OK.
I think you should be able to
follow what I'm going to say.
So for simplicity, right
now let me consider
zero cosmological constant.
OK, zero cosmological constant.
OK, zero cosmological
constant corresponding to-- we
consider symptotically
Minkowski space time.
And so in the space time of zero
cosmological constant entered
in the space time metric
due to an object of mass m.
It can be written as-- so this
is the famous Schwarzschild
metric.
And so of course
here we are assuming
this is a spherical symmetric,
and a neutral, et cetera.
So this object does
not carry any charge.
And this m and this f--
it's given by 1 minus 2m,
mass divided by r, or it's
equal to rs divided by r.
OK, so this rs is the
Schwarzschild radius.
So now c is always equal to 1.
So if this object-- so
we consider this object
is very close metric center.
If this object have finite
sides, then of course
this metric only is varied
outside this object.
But if the sides
of this object is
smaller than the
Schwarzschild radius,
then this is a black hole.
OK, and the black hold is
distinguished by event horizon
and r equal to rs.
OK, and the r equal to rs.
So at r equal to rs, you
see that this f becomes 0.
OK, so f equals become 0.
So essentially at here gtt-- so
the metric for the tt component
is becomes 0, and the grr, the
metric before the r component
become infinite.
And another thing is that when
r becomes smaller than rs,
the f switch sign.
So f become active, and then
in this case then the r become
time coordinates and the t
becomes spatial coordinates,
when you go inside
to the r equal to rs.
OK, this is just a
feature of this metric.
So now let me say some simple
fact about this metric.
So most of them I
expect you know--
I expect you know of them.
But just to remind you
some of those facts
will be important later.
OK, so these are
mostly reminders.
So first, this metric-- if you
look at this metric itself,
it's time reversal invariant.
OK, because if you
take t go to minus t,
of course the invariant
on the t goes to minus t.
OK, so this-- actually,
because of this,
this cannot describe
a real black hole.
So the real life black hole
arise from the gravitational
collapse, and the gravitational
collapse cannot be a time
symmetric process, OK?
So this cannot describe-- so
this does not describe a real
black hole, but it's a good
approximation to the real life
black hole after this
object have stabilized.
So after the gravitational
collapse has finished.
So this is a mathematical--
in some sense,
it is a mathematical
idealization
of real life black hole.
OK, so this is first remark.
So the second remark is that
despite this grr goes infinity,
this metric component
goes infinity.
So the space time is
non-singular at the horizon.
OK, so you can check
it by computing,
say, curvature invariants
of this metric.
You find the number of the--
all the curvature invariant
that are well-defined.
So this horizon is
just the coordinate--
you can show that
this horizon is just
a coordinate singularity.
Which we will see--
actually, we will see it
in maybe next lecture, or maybe
at the end of today's lecture,
that just this
coordinate, r and the t,
coordinate become singular.
The coordinate itself
become singular.
So this t, we normally
call it Schwarzschild time.
So let me just introduce a name.
So this t, we call it
the Schwarzschild time.
So Schwarzschild
found this solution
while fighting first World
War, really in the battlefield.
And a couple months after
he finished this metric,
he died from some disease.
Right, this is that.
So another thing, you
can easily check yourself
with r equal to rs-- the
horizon is a null surface-- is
a null hyper surface.
It's a null hyper surface.
The null hyper surface just
say this surface contains
geodesics which are null.
And this is a-- the third remark
is an extremely important one,
which we will use many
times in the future.
We said the horizon is a surface
of infinite red shift compared
to the-- infinite red shift
from the perspective of observed
infinity, OK?
So let me save time, now, to
add to this qualifying remark
from the perspective
of observed infinity.
So now let me just illustrate
this point a little bit more
explicitly.
So let's consider observer--
consider an observer-- so
let me call oh-- at some
hyper surface r, which
is close to the horizon.
Yeah, say as someplace which
Slightly outside the horizon.
And let us consider
another observer,
which I call o infinity,
which at i go to infinity.
OK, very far away
from the black hole.
So let's first look
at this observer.
So the i equals infinity,
then your metric-- so at i
equals infinity, this
f just becomes one,
because when your r goes to
infinity, this r just become 1.
And then this become the
standard Minkowski space
time, written in the
spherical coordinates.
So we just have the standard
Minkowski time written
in spherical coordinates.
And then from here
you can immediately
see-- so this t is what we
call Schwarzschild time.
t is the proper time for
this observed infinity.
Say, for o infinity.
OK, so now let's look at
someplace i equal to rh.
So at i equal to
rh, then the metric
is given by minus f rh
dt squared with the rest.
OK, and to define the proper
time for the observer at-- we
can just directly write
it as minus d tau squared.
So that's the proper
time observed by observer
at this hyper surface, OK?
So then we concludes--
so let me call it tau h.
So we conclude that
the problem time for oh
is given by f 1/2 rh times dt.
OK, so it relates to the
proper time at infinity
by this factor.
So if I write it more
explicitly-- so this
is 1 minus rh, divided
by rs 1/2 times dt.
So we see that as rh--
suppose this observer--
the location of this observer
approach the horizon, say,
if rh approach to rs, then
this d tau h divided by dt
will go to 0.
So that means
compared to the time
at infinity the time at r equal
to rs becomes infinite now.
So-- or approximate, let me
say, becomes infinite now.
So that means any
finite interval--
any finite proper time
interval for observer at oh--
for this oh-- when you
view [INAUDIBLE] infinity
become infinitely null, OK?
Become very long time scale.
OK, become very long time scale.
So you can also
invert this relation.
OK, you can also invert
the recent relation.
Say, suppose some
event of energy
with energy eh--
with proper energy
eh-- say, for this observer
at oh, for this observer oh.
Then because of the time
relation between them,
because of the time
then from the perspective
of this observer at infinity
the energy is given just but
you invert the [INAUDIBLE]
between the time, because of
the energy and time conjugate.
So the e infinity becomes
eh times this f 1/2 rh.
So for this just again says,
in a slightly different way,
that for any finite eh local
proper energy-- so this
is a local proper energy
for the observer at oh--
this e infinity--
the same event viewed
form the perspective of the
observer at infinity goes to 0.
S rh goes to rs.
So that e is infinity
red shifted--
become infinite red shift.
So any process with
local proper energy
viewed from infinity
corresponding
to very, very low
energy process.
So this actually will play
a very important role.
This feature will play
a very important role
when later we talk about
holographic duality
and it's implication, say, for
the field series, et cetera.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So this is
just a pedantic comment,
but I think you need a minus
sign in front of your f,
just to make sure proper
time isn't imaginary.
PROFESSOR: Sorry,
which minus sign?
AUDIENCE: In the d tau stage.
PROFESSOR: You mean here?
You mean here or here?
AUDIENCE: Below that.
PROFESSOR: Below that,
yeah-- oh, sorry, sorry.
Thank you, I wrote it wrong.
It should be rs rh.
Yeah, because rs is above.
Sorry, yeah-- so rs is above, so
varied rh, so rh is downstairs.
Thank you, so rh is--
so I always consider rh
as [INAUDIBLE] equal to rs, OK?
Any other questions?
OK, and so some other fact.
And again, I will
just list them.
I will just them.
If you're not
familiar with them,
it should be very easy for
you to go through them,
to re-derive them, with a
little bit knowledge in gr.
So number four is that it takes
a free fall-- free fall means
we just follow geodesics--
free fall of a traveler
a finite proper time
to reach the horizon--
say, from the infinity-- but
infinite Schwarzschild time.
So also you can easily
check that it actually
takes infinite Schwarzschild
time for object
to fall through the horizon.
But from the free
fall observer itself,
it's actually just
finite proper time.
And so from the perspective
of the observer at infinity,
it looks like this object
never fall into the black hole.
It's just frozen at the horizon.
So another remark is that
once inside the horizon-- that
means when r becomes
smaller than rs--
the traveler can not
send signals to outside,
nor can he escape.
So that's why this is
called even horizon.
So we will see this
slightly later.
In next lecture we will
see this explicitly.
So finally, there are two
important geometric quantities
associated with the horizon.
Two important geometric-- OK?
So the first one is the
area of the spatial section.
So suppose-- so let's consider
we are at i equal to rs,
and then here you just
said r equal to rs,
and then this is a
two-dimensional sphere, OK?
So this two-dimensional
sphere corresponding
to a spatial section
of the horizon.
So first, A is the area
of a spatial section.
So you can just say let's
look at the area of this part
with the r equal to
the horizon radius.
So this just give you a
equal to ah ah, equal to 4
pi rs squared.
And this rs is 2GN, so this
become 16 pi GN squared.
OK, so this is one of the key
quantities of a black hole
horizon.
It's what we call
the horizon area, OK?
What we call this horizon area.
And the B is called
the surface gravity.
B is called service gravity.
So the surface
gravity is defined
by the acceleration of
a stationary observer
at the horizon as
measured at infinity.
OK, at infinity means
at spatial infinity.
So you can-- if you are not
familiar with this concept
of surface gravity, you can
find it in standard textbooks.
For example, the Wald say page
158, and also section-- OK.
Just try to check it there.
So, say, suppose you
have a black hole.
Say this is the
Schwarzschild radius.
Of course, things want to
fall into the black hole.
So if you want to
remain at a fixed
location outside the black
hole, then you really
have to accelerate.
You have to fire some engine
to keep yourself to stay there.
And you can calculate what
is acceleration you need
to be able to stay here, OK?
And once you are closer
and closer to the horizon,
that acceleration becomes
bigger and bigger-- eventually,
becomes infinity when
you approach the horizon.
But because of this
red shift effect,
when this acceleration is viewed
from the units for observer
at affinity, then you have
infinity divided by infinity,
then turns out to be finite.
And this is called
a surface gravity.
It's normally called a kappa.
Normally called a kappa.
And this is one of
basic quantities--
basic geometric
quantities of the horizon.
So I will not derive it here.
I don't have time.
And if you want to
see this, Wald's book.
So you can calculate
that this is just
given by 1/2 the
derivative of this function
f evaluated at the
horizon location.
OK, so f is equal to 0 at the
horizon, but f prime is not.
OK, so you can easily calculate.
So this is 1 over 2rs from here,
and is equal to 1 over 4GN.
OK, so this is another
very important quantity
for the black hole.
Actually, I think right now
is a good place to stop.
OK, so let's stop
here for today,
and the next time we
will describe-- then
from here we will discuss
the causal structure
of the black hole, and then
you will see explicitly
some of this statement, if
you have not seen them before.